you comfortable with the fire and fury
rhetoric I mean I look I don't think
this is a you know two boxers doing
trash talk preparing for a fight in Las
Vegas I think this is very serious stuff
it effects the psyche of the other
country I think this is yet again
another example where President Trump
and his administration are not on the
same page not on the same message the
other person who had a very big problem
with it was a geometry the chair of the
Armed Services in the Senate its
uncoordinated it's irresponsible it's
impossible if they're just good-cop
bad-cop in North Korea that Tillerson
says everybody can calm down we're going
to figure this out diplomatically and
the president says fire and fury will
rain down on you if they want to be
unpredictable the only thing that's
predictable about them is that they're
inconsistent and that they're off manage
there you can have predictability but I
mean I have a hard time thinking that
this was a strategic well-thought-out
you know including by the way somebody
else that I I wonder what thought about
it because does have military experience
and take this very seriously if his new
chief of staff